مع استمرار حالات كوفيد 19 في الصعود ، فإن العديد من
المستشفيات تتعثر في اللحامات ،
وعلينا أن نعد أنفسنا لمعاودة
الارتفاع مرة أخرى بعد
عطلة يوم العمل وبالمناسبة بعد
ذهاب الأطفال إلى المدرسة سبب آخر
للقلق بشأن الأنفلونزا كل عام
تتسبب الأنفلونزا في إصابة الملايين بمرض
مئات الآلاف من الأشخاص في المستشفى
وعشرات الآلاف من الوفيات ، ولكن في
عام 2020 ، شهدت الولايات المتحدة عددًا منخفضًا للغاية
من حالات الإنفلونزا في العام الماضي ، وأعتقد أن لدينا
حالة واحدة في المستشفى لدينا الدكتور إريك
أدكنز مع أوهايو ستيت ويكسنر
يقول المركز الطبي إن العدد المنخفض من الحالات كان على
الأرجح بسبب تدابير الصحة العامة
مثل ارتداء الأقنعة والتباعد الجسدي ،
لكن هذا العام ،
كشف الكثيرون عن أن الحصول على لقاح الأنفلونزا
هو أحد أفضل الطرق لحماية
نفسك.
حالات الإنفلونزا المنخفضة تجعلك تشعر
بالراحة دون الحصول على اللقاح ووقت التفكير في الحصول على لقاح
الأنفلونزا هو الآن يوصي
مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC) بالحصول على لقاح الأنفلونزا  بحلول
نهاية أكتوبر ، تقول الوكالة إنه يمكن
تطعيم الأشخاص من كل من الأنفلونزا و covid19
في نفس الوقت لأنه يمكنك أيضًا التقاط
كلا الفيروسين ،
فمن المرجح أن يحتاجوا إلى دخول
المستشفى وقد يحتاجون أيضًا إلى مستوى رعاية صحية
محتمل  مع جهاز التنفس الصناعي للدقيقة الصحية
انا ماندي جيثر